no hair yeah yeah so when you're jerking
off you can kind of like
it feels like a woman yes yes that's
like an it's an enhance that's an
enhancement it's an enhancement trying
to call myself like i'm sort of a
lesbian in that way like i feel like i
am in a lesbian relationship because he
does feel like a very soft woman in my
arms
and i always that's always been a
turn-on for me
don't you wouldn't you say yeah i never
thought about that and you've always
liked my big broad manly shoulders i do
do you think that
maybe i lean more toward men and you
lean more toward women so i think
there's some truth to that maybe it's
just a little part of the brain though i
think yeah
yeah and sometimes when you're with
someone that comes out more you know
like i've been with i've been with some
women who are a little more masculine
and i felt that kind of come out that
part of the community come out right and
then i've been with girls who are a
little more submissive and i felt like
the masculine part yeah yeah it's like
all about the combination you're that
you're exactly right it depends who's in
front of you in that moment
yeah i don't like
i don't like masculine hands
oh yeah i have really pretty feminine
yeah i love hands like can we see it can
i see him yeah
those are [ __ ] feminine but they're
very long very long very feminine yeah
yeah i don't like butchy hand i mean
it's a guy he's not going to be in
trouble but i don't like
i mean i've seen some beautiful women
but yeah in this episode that's going to
be the thing
i'm so sorry i said bushy hands i said
butchie
cut out butchy's hands cut it out cut
that part out the unworthy
keep the all the sexist stuff on the
island and yeah yeah yeah
right
but like i've seen beautiful women but
their hands they don't manicure them
they're like thicker
you know they look like you know steve
simone's hand that means you're straight
i think ultimately
that's a good idea that's the test
that's the test that's the test yeah
yeah yeah
you can rest assured because i just feel
like you know if they're jerking me off
or they're and i look it just looks
weird i feel the same way well you have
you guys heard of the finger ratio and
depending on um what is it george so
it's your pointer
finger and your index finger can you
look that up yeah whatever will
determine this this is more for women
will determine whether or not you're um
gay
because in women i think if you have an
even um
length in two of your fingers you have a
higher um you have higher testosterone
right george which one is it
like if i turn my hands one way you know
one's longer and if i turn it the other
way the other's longer so i always try
to whenever anybody brings this up i try
to turn it the right way yeah maybe
you're just bi so the ratio between the
second and the fourth finger so it's
these these two look at this
oh they're even
they're well
these are even
this one and this one oh
this one's a little longer though no
they're pretty even minor even what does
that mean again then
why are there three of yours muffin
we're all three
it's a straight line
it's a straight line you're [ __ ]
weird dude
what is it what is that a little taller
it's a little taller but what is that
this looks like my penis without its
limb he's super gay huh yeah
so men on average have shorter index
fingers than ring fingers
while women typically have index and
ring fingers of similar lengths so for
me say for instance so technically on
most men they have this
longer than that but in your case it's
not it is a longer look look that i
really mean she's trying she's trying to
a little bit yeah wait mine's a little
long the ring is a little long but but
very like slightly it's not this yeah
you see i'm like angling it
i'm trying to help it i'm like wait a
second look look yeah look at you
yeah it's totally bigger yeah the
lighting i'm trying to do the lighting
optical illusion
yeah um but i think this is more for
women for women okay
thank god thank god yeah
and what about the like did they say if
there's an initial in your and that's
the person you're going to marry that's
a tick-tock trend
but what is it again what is it
tell me what it is it's like the the on
your thumb right here right um the lines
on your thumb it's a magnifying thing on
tick tock right that's i don't think
that's like science i'm not sure if
that's science yeah it's not it's no no
that's sure because i don't see but i
was thinking like i don't see like look
at check this out
a a letter but what if it's in korean on
mine
means your soulmate
right what i'm saying is because i'm
korean yeah right
do do you think the symbol would be in
english
i'm not sure
are you north korean or south korean i
never asked oh north for sure oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh you're north oh no no
i'm [ __ ] stuck but i think that like
you know also all
all said and done you guys you and i are
the same number in terms of sweet
hotness yeah i agree so you don't think
and we also are with women who are way
out of our league exactly my wife is
like super hot yeah yeah
do you think that you're better looking
than giannis
be honest no no i think that him and i
because it's high you have to what do
you think he has he has a greek scale
yeah i have a korean scale and i think
in both scales and compare it right
would be the same number i don't know
what that beat would be yeah